let's take a listen to what the piano
apps say well it's great to be here at
cop to build on the legacy of Glasgow
but also continue the leadership that
our country has shown in tackling
climate change now of course this is
about the the future and the planet that
we leave our children but it's also
about the here and now at home many
people are grappling with very
as a result of Russia's illegal War so
that just highlights the need to move
quickly to improve our energy security
to transition to cheaper safer cleaner
forms of energy but I've also had the
opportunity here to talk to world
leaders including president macron about
all the different ways that we can work
together including tackling illegal
migration and I'll come to that in a
second on the specific of the climate
fund the money and the time frame are
you committed to what was set out before
yeah we remain committed to the 11.6
billion that we announced last year for
international climate finance and
actually today you know we're seeing the
benefit that that can bring to countries
around the world as we help countries
like Kenya for example transition to Net
Zero that actually is also bringing
exciting opportunities for British
companies it's involving the private
sector which is the right thing to do
but also helping those countries
transition to a cleaner future creating
jobs in the process I know you're not
committing to the time frame and if it's
a longer time frame that's a dilution
isn't it no the plan was to do this over
five years now the exact pace of this
always is dependent on the projects
being ready at the right time but we
remain committed to those plans I'm
making that commitment again in my
statement later today you've just met
the president of France as you as you
mentioned what in specific terms are you
and he going to do about this growing
problem of people crossing the channel
in small boats you know it's great to
meet president macron to talk about not
just tackling illegal migration but the
range of other areas in which we want to
cooperate closely with the French on but
also is remember that this is an issue
that affects many countries it's and
actually I've been talking to other
European leaders as well about our share
challenge in tackling illegal migration
and I think there is an opportunity for
us to work closely not just with the
French but with other countries as well
you know you will hear more details
about that in the coming weeks as those
conversations happen amongst all our
teams but I'm actually leaving this with
renewed confidence and optimism that
working together with our European
Partners we can make a difference grip
this challenge of illegal migration and
stop people coming illegally by when and
by what kind of order of magnitude how
how soon will things improve how soon
will fewer people be attempting those
perilous Crossings well look we all want
this situation to resolve itself as
quickly as possible I also want to be
honest with people that it it's it's a
complex issue it doesn't it's not one
Simple Solution that's going to solve it
overnight I wouldn't be being honest if
I said that there was there's a range of
things we need to do but what I want
people to be reassured by that I
absolutely am determined to grip this
I've been spending enormous amount of my
own time on it I've been talking to
several European leaders about it today
and there's a range of things that we
will action as quickly as we can to get
a grip of this situation and and reduce
the amount of illegal migration that
we're seeing you say you want to be
honest about this it's not the honest
truth that your Home Secretary the
person you chose to appoint as Home
Secretary just six days after she'd
resigned from that post has made the
situation worse made it worse at manston
where plenty of people according to some
have been held unlawfully look the Home
Secretary is actually at the moment
making sure that we reduce the numbers
at manston and we're making very good
progress on that and and we actually
returned that operation to where we
would all like to see it but in the long
term that to make sure that we don't
have a situation that we saw at Manson
happening again we need to we need to
reduce the number of people coming here
illegally now that's going to require
the Home Secretary and others to work
constructively with Partners around
Europe to stop people coming in the
first place and there's a range of
things we need to do to make that a
reality that's what the Home Secretary
is focused on and that's what I'm
focused on as well you appointed a
minister sir Gavin Williamson who was
abusive and foul-mouthed in his
conversations via text with a with a
colleague to that amount of bullying
there's an independent complaint
investigation that is happening and it's
right that we let that that process run
its course before passing judgment
happening inside it's up and running is
it yes yes that is there's an
independent complaints investment
process that is happening and I want to
see the results of that obviously but
I've been very clear at the language is
not right it's not acceptable and that's
why I welcome the fact that Gavin
Williamson has expressed regret about
that and now we'll wait to see what the
investigation says if it's not
acceptable why on Earth are you keeping
him as a minister well as I said there's
a there's an independent complaints
process that's being conducted at the
moment it would be right to let that
process conclude before making any
decisions about the future let me ask
you about the case of Allah Abdel fattah
the British citizen who's on Hunger
Strike now on water strike in jail here
you've promised to raise this with the
Egyptian authorities here have you
managed to do that into what effect yeah
I am hoping to see the president Susie
later today will I will of course raise
uh this issue it's something that not
just the United Kingdom that many
countries want to see resolved
let me ask you about Matt Hancock a
former cabinet colleague now out eating
goodness knows what in the Australian
Outback one of your fellow conservative
MPS your view on what he is doing
you know I've said already that I think
it's it was a disappointing decision
that he made to participate in the
program at this time and I very much
support the decision that the chief whip
has taken to suspend the conservative
whip from Matt Hancock so he's no longer
a conservative MP right now will he be
in the future will he get it back I said
these whipping matters are of course a
question for the chief but yeah but no
but I've been very clear that I was very
disappointed with the decision he made I
think there's lots for us all to be
getting on with at this time and that's
what I think people should be focused on
Final question I promise Boris Johnson
has said he is here in a purely
supportive role how would you describe
it oh it's great that the former prime
minister is here and I think it says
something you know if it says something
great about the UK that not only have we
got the current prime minister here
we've got a former prime minister here
it just demonstrates our leadership on
this issue globally you know and Boris
was a stallwall champion of building a
Greener future he deserves enormous
credit and prays for that and as I said
it's enormous credit to the UK that we
have not just one but also a former
prime minister here that's a UK leading
on tackling climate change something we
should all be proud of thank you